mesdames messieurs bon dimanche Justin
Trudeau n'aurait pu espérer meilleure
visite de passage à Ottawa pour son
premier voyage officiel Joe Biden n'a eu
que de bons mots pour le Canada
soulignant l'importance et la force de
l'amitié des liens qui unissent les deux
pays les deux hommes ont annoncé la fin
des passages irréguliers où je mets
Roxane plusieurs engagements en matière
de défense d'économie et d'environnement
articulés autour d'une vision commune
sans compromettre les valeurs et les
intérêts de chacun
c'est pas le moment de faire des
compromis sur nos valeurs oui
alors le Canada a-t-il obtenu tout ce
qu'il souhaitait de cette rencontre je
pose la question à François Philippe
champagne il est ministre de
l'innovation des Sciences et de
l'Industrie monsieur champagne merci
d'être avec nous en ce beau dimanche
matin
c'est un grand plaisir écoutez pour
répondre à votre question ça serait
difficile de vouloir plus parce que
c'était une visite historique les gens
l'ont vu on a parlé d'environnement on a
parlé d'économie on a parlé de sécurité
vous savez un peu tout ce que nous on
avait mis sur la table on a parlé
d'espace tout ce qu'on avait mis sur la
table c'est des sujets qui sont revenus
durant la visite même dans le discours
du président la Chambre des communes
alors moi je vous dirais mission
accomplie certainement pour le Canada
dans cette grande visite le plus gros
gain du gouvernement de votre
gouvernement est-ce que c'est Roxane on
a beaucoup parlé de Roxane est-ce que
est-ce que c'est ça l'élément le plus
important c'est un point important parce
que il fallait trouver une solution à
cet enjeu là ça préoccupait beaucoup de
gens mais je vous dirai au-delà de ça
ce qui ressort de cette visite là c'est
le sens de faire plus ensemble vous
savez quand le président américain dit
puis je regardais même sans fil média
qui disait vous savez quand on travaille
avec le Canada on arrive à faire de
grandes choses et ça c'est important
parce que vous savez quand le président
américain passe c'est pas nécessairement
juste un auditoire canadien mais il
parle un auditoire américaine voire un
auditoire mondial alors
cette reconnaissance là de la nature
unique de notre relation avec les
Américains elle est importante
importante au niveau de la sécurité elle
est importante au niveau économique
écoutez quand vous avez dans le discours
du président américain qu'on parle de
Bromont cette idée-là qu'on a lancé il y
a quelques mois d'avoir un grand
corridor sur les semis conducteurs quand
vous parlez qu'on va aller sur la Lune
ensemble on va aller en orbite autour de
la Lune ensemble c'est des messages
forts et certainement
ça facilite votre travail
bah oui parce que écoutez nous on
reprend ça moi vous savez je vais être à
Houston lundi prochain prononcé le ou
l'astronaute canadien qui sera en orbite
avec les Américains autour de la Lune on
sera le deuxième pays au monde à faire
ça évidemment le président parle avant
ça met la table ça met la table aussi au
niveau économique ça met la table au
niveau toute l'industrie qu'on veut
bâtir ensemble puis cette reconnaissance
là d'une relation privilégiée quand tu
parlais des échanges commerciaux 2.5
milliards de dollars par jour vous savez
nous on le sait ces choses-là on sait
nous au Canada monsieur Thibault mais
quand un président américain les
reconnaît le dit mais ça donne une
grande valeur évidemment pour faciliter
le travail il y a un élément pour lequel
vous avez quand même essayer de la
critique c'est l'absence d'exhension aux
mesures protectionnistes du bail
américain pourquoi qu'est-ce qui bloque
de ce côté-là
des enjeux il y en aura toujours je
reprends les mots je pense du premier
secrétien que vous savez des enjeux dans
des relations municipales il y en a au
niveau provincial fédéral dans les
entreprises il y en a toujours par
contre je pense que
l'esprit vous avez regardé combien de
fois le président américain a parlé de
l'Amérique du Nord dans son discours ça
ça a été retenu aussi par les
intervenants du côté de la frontière
c'est important pour plusieurs
entreprises canadiennes
prenez seulement les semis conducteurs
monsieur Thibault le fait que le
président parle de cette intégration là
que par exemple que ça vienne de sa
bouche que la plus grande usine parce
qu'on appelle faire les tests ce qu'on
appelle la mise la mise en place de ces
semis conducteurs-là soit du côté
canadien voir au Québec
c'est fort comme symbole ça donne une
image qu'il faut faire plus ensemble
c'est sûr qu'on va continuer de faire
vous savez c'est jamais mission
complètement complet il faut toujours
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire de
plus pour s'insérer dans les chaînes un
événement stratégique aux États-Unis bon
le fait là je vous dirais pour des semis
conducteurs au niveau de l'automobile au
niveau des minéraux critiques mais mais
vous l'avez entendu comme moi le premier
président américain qui moi ce que je
chantais c'était cet esprit là ensemble
on fait plus et ça ça va avoir je pense
un impact sur les différentes politiques
sur les règlements qui vont être adoptés
vous avez vous avez réussi à faire des
avancées importantes effectivement mais
clairement encore des éléments où est-ce
qu'il y a du travail à faire la question
du bain le bois d'oeuvre qui est un
contentieux qui retourne sur des
décennies qui a pas été réglées non plus
j'en parlais que Monsieur Créteil
justement ça fait longtemps ces
histoires là mais il faut toujours
pousser pour toujours le mentionner le
premier sur le mentionner dans dans la
rencontre bilatérale alors on est
toujours là à faire avancer mais c'est
sûr que dans une relation qui est aussi
importante qui est aussi vaste a
tellement de niveau vous comprendrez
monsieur Thibault il y aura toujours des
enjeux c'est normal il y en a dans les
relations fédérales provinciales
imaginez quand vous avez un partenaire
comme les américains il y en aura
toujours ceci dit je pense que le temps
du discours du président Baden est
important parce que les gens prennent
beaucoup j'allais dire
leur
leur position face au temps du président
elle tombe du président était celui
vraiment de Canada c'est un allié c'est
un ami c'est un partenaire stratégique
en matière de défense on a parlé de
Norade on a parlé de l'espace on a parlé
au niveau économique on a parlé de
l'environnement on a réglé la question
de Roxane c'est quand même vous en
conviendrez monsieur Thibault c'est
quand même beaucoup en l'espace de
quelques pense 24 heures et aussi c'est
rare en terminant c'est rare qu'on a la
tension de l'administration américaine
pendant 24 heures et plus et ça pour moi
c'est important parce qu'au-delà de
toute la partie officielle il y a eu
quand même beaucoup de d'échanges
bilatéraux avec son équipe on a passé
des heures avec les gens
d'administration américaine et ça je
vous dirai c'est assez important parce
que les relations c'est pas
nécessairement dans les rencontres
bilatérales mais c'est dans tout ce qui
est autour on a la chance de se parler
de ce qu'on prend et d'échanger ça ça a
une valeur inestimable là vous votre
travail c'est de prendre ça puis de
porter le ballon puis d'aller chercher
des investissements à l'extérieur du
pays puis de ramener ça ici quelle est
la carte quel est qu'est-ce que vous
mettez sur la table pour dire à une
compagnie étrangère venez chez nous
maintenant
le talent certainement c'est ce qui
attire les gens chez nous les
écosystèmes se présentent à parler des
écosystèmes forts des deux côtés de la
frontière des minéraux critiques ça a
été mentionné durant la visite on parle
d'énergie renouvelables je pense que
cette volonté là de décarboner plusieurs
chaînes d'approvisionnement finalement
l'accès au marché c'est ce qui fait que
les gens viennent chez nous mais souvent
le Canada c'est pas un pays de 38
millions mais c'est un pays qui donne
accès à un point 5 milliards de
consommateurs à travers le monde mais la
table est mise je pense que vous l'avez
bien saisis monsieur Thibault il y a ce
sens là que le président veut qu'on
fasse plus ensemble il a mentionné à
plusieurs niveaux ce qu'on pourrait
faire plus alors nous on prend ça moi je
vais prendre cette balle là retourner à
Washington retournez à New York mais
c'est des messages forts vous
comprendrez parce que quand un président
parle c'est surtout les messages qu'il
envoie et vous avez vu à l'instant même
que le président disait ça
l'administrateur de la NASA pour vous
donner un exemple répondait tout de
suite sur Twitter c'est important parce
que c'est avec le Canada qu'on fait des
grandes choses rapidement
vous avez vous avez un budget qui s'en
vient mardi qu'est-ce qui doit avoir
là-dedans pour enligner la politique
fiscale canadienne à la politique
fiscale américaine en matière
d'incitative pour les entreprises
je pense que c'est l'économie verte
certainement il y a eu des messages clés
qui ont été développés durant cette
visite là par le président l'idée aussi
qu'on doit répondre
mais je pense que la ministre des
finances étaient là on va être là pour
les gens on va être là aussi pour
assurer la compétitivité la
compétitivité du Canada long terme et on
sera là évidemment pour s'assurer que on
crée les emplois d'aujourd'hui mais
aussi pour pour ce domaine on l'a déjà
fait vous avez Volkswagen un bel exemple
politique industrielle qui fait des
dividendes je dirais pour les
générations Philippe champagne merci
infiniment d'avoir été les nôtres
toujours un plaisir merci à vous bon
dimanche